bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les trous de ver selon la théorie
de la relativité générale notre univers
est une hyper surface à quatre
dimensions dans laquelle évoluent les
astres et tous les objets c'est l'espace
temps cet espace temps n'est pas rigide
il possède une certaine géométrie qui va
se déformer sous la présence de masse et
énergie il peut se courber c'est cette
courbure qui est notamment la base de la
gravitation un trou noir est un objet
dont toute la masse est concentrée en un
seul point qu'on appelle la singularité
de par sa masse le trou noir des formes
l'espace temps autour de lui à partir
d'une certaine proximité l'espace temps
est tellement courbet que tous les
objets et même la lumière ne peuvent
plus s'en échapper un trou noir possède
ainsi un horizon une sphère à
l'intérieur de laquelle la courbure
spatio-temporelle devient tellement
forte qu'il est impossible de revenir en
arrière pour mieux visualiser le trou
noir
on peut représenter sa géométrie en
effectuant ce qu'on appelle en
mathématiques aims plongement
le plongement va nous fournir une figure
géométrique qui reproduit fidèlement les
propriétés de courbure de l'espace
autour du trou noir
après calcul on peut observer que
l'espace autour du trou noir se comporte
à la façon d'un entonnoir à grande
distance
il est relativement plat c'est à dire
très peu courbé mais plus on se
rapproche de l'horizon plus la courbure
s'intensifie étonnamment à première vue
on a l'impression que la structure même
de l'univers contient un trou
l'existence de ce trou peut paraître
étrange on peut se demander ce qui se
passerait par exemple si un vaisseau
spatial en atteignait la bordure
l'univers s'arrête-t-il au niveau du
trou pour répondre à cette question il
est nécessaire de comprendre une
subtilité mathématiques notre univers et
en particulier l'espace-temps possède
quatre dimensions trois dimensions des
espaces et une dimension de temps mais
en représentant la géométrie de l'espace
on s'est affranchi de deux de ses
dimensions d'une part l'horizon du trou
noir est censé être une sphère mais ici
pour pouvoir représenter l'espace temps
on a supprimé une dimension des espaces
on s'est placé dans un plan et l'horizon
apparaît donc comme un cercle d'autre
part on n'a représenté que la courbure
de l'espace mais pas le temps on a
délibérément retirer la dimension
temporelle de notre diagrammes
en conséquence le diagramme est figé il
ne représente la courbure de l'espace
qu'à un seul et unique instant dans le
temps
lorsqu'il tombe vers le trou noir notre
vaisseau spatial avance dans le temps
en effet si le ton ne s'écoulait pas le
vaisseau serait figé il ne pourrait pas
progressé ainsi lorsqu'on s'intéresse à
la chute du vaisseau au cours du temps
il est nécessaire de faire également
évoluer notre plongement pour que celui
ci représente bel et bien la courbure de
l'espace à l'instant vécu par le
vaisseau et lorsqu'on fait évoluer le
diagramme de cette façon on observe que
le trou se referme très rapidement sur
lui-même lorsqu'il atteint l'horizon du
trou noir
le vaisseau est en mesure de le
traverser il continue sa chute vers la
singularité centrale mathématiquement on
peut démontrer que quel que soit
l'observateur et même pour un rayon
lumineux
cette sorte de trou dans l'univers va
toujours se refermer suffisamment vite
de sorte à être absolument inatteignable
selon la relativité générale la
structure de l'espace peut admettre un
tel trou mais celui ci est
nécessairement destiné à se refermer sur
lui-même extrêmement vite de sorte qu'il
est impossible de l'atteindre l'univers
ne possède donc pas réellement de trous
mais d'un point de vue de notre
imagination et de l'élégance
mathématiques
cette réponse n'est pourtant pas très
satisfaisantes même s'il se referme très
vite le trou semble bel et bien existé
pendant un bref instant ce qui peut
paraître bizarre
en l'occurrence on a l'impression qu'il
manque quelque chose à notre théorie que
celle-ci ne décrit pas parfaitement la
situation
avec les mathématiques il est possible à
l'intérieur des équations de dupliquer
la géométrie de l'espace d'en faire une
copie
mais en sens inverse dans cette version
inversée
la copie du trou noir se comportent
différemment au lieu de tout absorbé
inexorablement elle recrache tous les
objets sans que rien même la lumière ne
puisse jamais y entrer c'est ce qu'on
appelle un troublant où parfois une
fontaine blanche
maintenant que l'on dispose de sept
copies de l'espace temps on va pouvoir
venir la colle et en dessous de notre
trou initial cette manoeuvre
mathématiques et quelque peu
artificielle et aucune observation
physique ne permet de la justifier il
s'agit d'une extension mathématiques qui
est principalement motivée par la
symétrie des équations
d'un point de vue des mathématiques on
forme ainsi une structure beaucoup plus
satisfaisante qui prend la forme d'un
tube et non plus d'un simple trou c'est
ce genre de structure en forme de tube
qu'on appelle un trou de fer
si une telle structure existe le trou de
ver doit nécessairement relier deux
parties d'espace-temps peut-être qu'il
relie deux univers indépendant mais
peut-être aussi qu'il relie deux
endroits différents à l'intérieur d'un
seul et même univers
ils formeraient ainsi un raccourci
géométriques entre ces deux régions que
la lumière ou les objets pourraient
peut-être emprunter pour se rendre plus
rapidement d'un endroit à l'autre en
laissant libre cours à notre imagination
on peut très vite s'imaginer un futur
dans lequel des vaisseaux spatiaux
traverserait de tels raccourcis dans
l'espace temps pour voyager de galaxies
en galaxies
mais ce trou de ver en question qui est
formé d'un trou noir et d'un troublant
qu'on surnomme également le pont dan
steinbock jeunes ne peut pas être
traversés en effet comme on l'a vu
précédemment sa structure de tubes qui
est l'extension du trou se referme
extrêmement rapidement sur elle-même
étranglant tout observateur qui s'y
aventurent de cette façon il est
impossible de le traverser et on peut
uniquement se diriger vers la
singularité du trou noir
fort heureusement pour notre curiosité
il existe cependant d'autres géométrie
de trous de ver qui sont
mathématiquement acceptable selon la
relativité générale et dont les
propriétés sont plus avantageuses tout
d'abord si un trou noir est en rotation
sur lui-même ou qu'il possède une charge
électrique
il pourrait être possible cette fois ci
de traverser le trou de ver qui lui est
associée car dans ce cas la singularité
au centre n'est plus un point mais un
anneau ce qui génère autour d'elle un
nouvel horizon à travers lequel il est
possible de passer
cela dit ce trou de ver ne serait
traversable que dans un seul sens car
après en être sorti on ne peut pas
rentrer dans le troublant de physiciens
théoriciens ont donc mis au point des
géométries plus sophistiquées avec des
propriétés plus intéressante qui
s'affranchissent des trous noirs étaient
troublants pour être plus propice un
réel voyage
ces trous de ver purement mathématiques
sont conçus pour obéir à certaines
conditions de faisabilité
premièrement on veut que notre trou de
ver soit traversable dans les deux sens
contrairement au pont d'einstein rosen
il doit donc être dépourvu de toute
forme d'horizon de sorte que chaque
endroit soit franchissable dans un sens
comme dans l'autre
deuxièmement le trou de ver doit être
stable dans le temps en effet s'il se
referme sur lui-même ou qu'il est
instable
il pourrait être risqué de l'exploiter
pour des voyages
troisièmement pour pouvoir le traverser
sans encombre le tube qui forment le
trou de ver doit être suffisamment large
sinon il serait tout simplement
impossible d'y entrer
quatrièmement le temps nécessaire à
traverser le trou de ver doit être
raisonnable par exemple quelques années
en effet si le voyage prend plusieurs
milliards d'années le trou de ver n'a
pas de grande utilité
et pour finir les forces de gravité qui
sont générés par sa géométrie ne doivent
pas être trop prononcé de sorte à ne pas
trop abîmer ou étirer la structure du
vaisseau qui le traverse serait
mathématiquement il existe de telles
géométrie qui sont bel et bien accepté
par la théorie de la relativité générale
l'un des exemples les plus simples et le
trou de ver de maurice thorn le trou de
ver de maurice thorn possède de
nombreuses propriétés très intéressante
il ne comporte pas d'horizon pas de
singularité il est parfaitement stable
dans le temps et contrairement au pont
d'einstein rosen
il ne va pas se refermer au moment où le
traversent ce trou de ver est
particulièrement intéressant du fait
qu'il est purement géométriques
c'est à dire que sa structure bien
particulière lui permet de ne pas
générer de gravité
ainsi il est possible de rester immobile
à côté d'un tel trou de ver sans que
celui ci ne nous attire ou ne nous
repousse lorsqu'on essaye de le franchir
notre vaisseau va se déplacer le long
d'une géodésique c'est à dire une ligne
droite à l'intérieur de l'espace temps
courbes et les géodésique du trou de ver
de maurice thorn sont bien particulière
certaines trajectoires entre dans le
trou de ver font quelques tours à
l'intérieur mais finissent par ressortir
du tube du même côté par lequel ils sont
entrés pour traverser ce trou de ver
étant donné qu'ils ne génèrent pas de
gravité pour nous attirer il est donc
nécessaire de bien diriger son vaisseau
vers l'intérieur du trou en apparence
comme pour un trou noir
les rayons lumineux sont déviés par
cette géométrie le trou de ver agit donc
comme une lentille qui déforme l'image
des étoiles environnantes
mais du fait que les rayons lumineux
peuvent également le traverser on peut
aussi y observer les astres qui se
trouvent de l'autre côté et donc
visualiser à l'avance la zone de
l'univers par laquelle il nourrit le
trou de ver de maurice thorn et
particulièrement élégant et il semble
remplir toutes les conditions
nécessaires à la possibilité d'un voyage
intergalactique
mais tout n'est pas si simple son
existence nécessite en effet de le
stabiliser
en plaçant autour de lui une sphère
d'énergie négative cette énergie
négative permet de s'opposer à
l'attention de l'espace-temps qui
forcent continuellement les structures
de ce type à s'étrangler sur elle même
comme on l'a vu avec le pont d'einstein
rosen mais malheureusement dans le cadre
de la relativité générale on peut
démontrer mathématiquement qu'une telle
énergie négative n'est pas possible et
donc que les trous de ver stable ne
peuvent pas exister aussi décevant que
cela puisse paraître les trous de ver
sont donc impossible du point de vue de
la relativité générale car leur
existence en tant que structure stable
nécessite de l'énergie négative sur une
longue durée ce qui n'est
mathématiquement pas possible ce
principe très fort est appelé le
théorème de censure topologique il nous
indique que toute structure de type
trous de ver va se censurer
automatiquement
c'est à dire se refermer sur elle-même
pour tout observateur qui tentent de
l'atteindre mais ces conclusions très
définitives sont basés sur la relativité
générale
or on sait aujourd'hui que cette théorie
n'est pas parfaite en particulier ne
prend pas forcément en compte certains
phénomènes quantiques qui se produisent
aux échelle microscopique à ces échelles
d'autres théories entre en jeu et
notamment la théorie quantique des
champs
selon cette théorie qui décrit les
particules à l'échelle quantique le vide
possède une certaine énergie qui est
sans cesse agitée de fluctuation ces
fluctuations sont appelés des particules
virtuelles et on peut les assimiler à
des particules ordinaire qui
apparaîtrait puis disparaît très très
rapidement toutes ces particules
virtuelles génère une sorte de pression
résiduelle dans l'espace qui va dans
certaines configurations agir de façon
analogue à une énergie négative
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet casimir
ainsi même si la relativité générale à
elle seule semble repoussé l'idée de
trous de ver stable les phénomènes de la
physique quantique pourrait peut-être
apporter une solution
certains scientifiques entre voit déjà
des parallèles entre les trous de ver
est le phénomène de l'intrication
quantique
de plus certaines théories encore
spéculative et notamment la théorie des
cordes offre de nouvelles perspectives
d' approche pour l'existence de trous de
ver naturel qui se serait formé juste
après le big bang et qui aurait été
étirés après leur création par
l'expansion de l'univers
en théorie des cordes de tels trous de
ver serait stabilisé par des cordes
cosmiques qui sont des objets pour
l'instant purement hypothétique
pour finir si l'existence des trous de
ver parvenait à être prouvée et
soulèverait la question du voyage dans
le temps en effet la théorie de la
relativité qui travaillent non pas sur
l'espace mais sur l'espace temps
n'empêche pas un tel objet de relier
deux instants différents
pour le moment on ne sait toujours pas
si le voyage dans le passé est possible
mais peut-être que de telles structures
le rendrait envisageable cela dit pour
des raisons de cohérence
un trou de ver ne pourrait certainement
pas permettre de revenir plus loin dans
le passé que l'instant même de sa
création
les trous de ver sont des objets
mathématiques fascinant dont l'étude
bien que complètement spéculative nous
permet de renforcer nos théories
actuelles en les mettant constamment à
l'épreuve et en tentant perpétuellement
de repousser leurs limites
bien que la possibilité de trous de ver
traversable ne soit toujours pas écartée
pour le moment les seules personnes a
traversé des trous de ver sont les
physiciens théoriciens munis de leurs
équations
moment